I'm going to take a moment to get this
repository on to my computer first I'll
make a directory called to do I'll CD
into it and i'm going to say get in it
that'll make an empty git repository i'm
also going to say get poll and this URL
here once that's done i should be able
to say get log and sure enough there are
all of the commits and that the same
commits that are here on github i'm
going to hop back to my terminal type Q
to get out of that and also if I happen
to pull it up in my finder here you'll
find that indeed we do have a to-do
application right here now one of the
very first things I do when I get a new
project is I run it in the browser now
sometimes this means setting up a local
server or installing this or that and
all those instructions are usually in
the readme in this application you can
see there is no read me and because this
case is fairly simple we can actually
just run it directly literally by
clicking and dragging index HTML here
into the browser if you have a local
server set up already on your computer
go ahead and use that and if you want to
explore local servers and learn how to
get them set up check out the link in
the instructor notes we're going to move
on right now in this case we can see
we're looking at a to-do application
this is really convenient because we
need to make a list of things to do here
are some good things to do when you
first get a code base first I always run
the application to see how it works then
I like to explore the file structure and
see what I can infer about the code
organization it's also important to look
at what JavaScript files are being
loaded sometimes people will use module
loaders which is just a fancy way of
saying a library that loads other
libraries in the correct order in this
case we don't have any complex stuff
going on things are staying simple so we
can just look in the bottom of the
index.html file to see what JavaScript
files are being loaded it's also super
important to spend some time figuring
out what all these libraries actually do
you probably already know what jQuery
does but what about the other libraries
that are being loaded now these are four
of the key things that I like to do when
I'm first exploring a code base now
we've already run the application in
fact i just did i'm running it right now
it's very convenient that hits a do do
application take a few minutes right
now to explore the file structure look
at what JavaScript files are loaded and
figure out what those libraries do
sometimes that means looking at their
code but most of the time it means
googling for them and seeing what their
home page says